[Musique]
j'ai grandi en Gaspésie j'ai eu des
enfants la vie tranquille avec le
travail
[Musique]
je me doucher criminel j'ai jamais vu
faire rien et toujours été un
travailleur qui doit
jamais j'aurais pu m'imaginer qu'il
allait me chercher comme Pablo Escobar
du Québec
c'est une histoire rocambolesque bien
sûr
des ballons et des ballots de cocaïne
les rexé du meurtre au deuxième degré de
Maxime Dugat Lepage qui était arrivé
c'est énorme c'est historique et ces
deux rêves de grandeur mais comme toute
bonne histoire
c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est passé
[Musique]
Martin Lepage je le connais depuis qu'on
est en France
son père était connu parce que c'était
le barbier du centre-ville de
Sainte-Anne-des-Monts que les gens ne
s'attendaient pas le faubourg
sa mère était infirmière auxiliaire je
crois donc pour moi c'était une famille
tout à fait ordinaire
leur rôle sur le boulevard René lapin
donc il y a beaucoup de la part d'un
point ici
[Musique]
ouais salut
monsieur tout le monde c'est bon
vraiment sympathique avenant qui est
toujours près des c'est la franchise en
été c'est le cas ça
quand j'avais à le rencontrer
[Musique]
à aller travailler puis à pas rester
couché le matin et toute ma vie
avec
des petits boulots et en même temps les
weekends j'allais en formation pour être
ambulancier
[Musique]
il va faire n'importe quoi pour plaire
à la femme
[Musique]
je vois la chasse
une fois par année on va passer une
dizaine de jours
en famille à la chasse à l'arc
comme les Indiens
a commencé là aussi avec les rêves qui
allaient avec
[Musique]
je rêve toujours d'aller sur un plus
gros bateau d'aller plus loin j'ai envie
d'aller faire une traversée de la
chantilly peut-être faire autour du
monde tu imagines plein de choses
[Musique]
partez des mois de temps il allait faire
de la voile parce que les gens
connaissaient peu de lui d'ailleurs
de d'être un amant de la voile puis
d'aimer voyager comme ça outre-mer
l'opportunité que j'attendais toute ma
vie privée
[Musique]
bonjour quelqu'un est ma prochaine puis
ça t'intéresserait pas de faire
le voyage en bateau ça se rapporte très
de l'argent
le but c'était de ramener un bateau pour
le vent
l'espace intérieur
donc on traverse la mer des Caraïbes en
ligne droite à la sortie
c'est de rejoindre le Canada
[Musique]
je te parle en vacances mais
puis je me suis quand même amusé un
petit peu
[Musique]
je suis douanier
notre travail c'est de contrôler tout ce
qui flotte
pas de vérifier que toutes les
marchandises transit vont statut légal
pour circuler 18 juillet 2018
je m'en souviendrai toute ma vie
nous appelle et on a un briefing à 10h
du matin alors qu'on n'est pas
spécialement parti pour faire une
mission à la mer et comme quoi
un bateau pourrait être intéressant en
haute mer le bateau s'appellerait le
living avec des personnes à bord
il y avait une personne qui avait été
attitrée pour venir avec moi
j'ai pas trouvé l'idée qui était
mauvaise on discute un petit peu avec
l'autre personne mais
on écoute le vin aussi
c'est un voile
il fait route au nord en fait
à peut-être 200 nautique à l'ouest des
Petites Antilles
la plupart des touristes font plutôt du
cabotage d'Ital en île c'est pas
extrêmement suspect mais effectivement
une route qui est un petit peu à l'écart
de leur touristique on va dire nous on
intervient à Saint-Martin quelquefois
dans l'année justement sur des bateaux
qui ont ce profil et une fois sur deux à
peu près il y a effectivement quelque
chose dessus une fois sur deux on a
travaillé il y a pas de résultats ça ça
peut arriver
on part sur une navigation d'à peu près
6 7 heures sans se mettre dans le rouge
on peut aller à 22 un voilier selon le
vent des fois trois deux quoi
tellement de vent non plus on n'avait
pas des vitesses vertigineuses avec le
bateau ça se passe doucement c'est
plutôt long l'interception obligatoire
en fait
[Musique]
ce jour-là la mer était pas très bonne
voilà la météo était plutôt dégradée en
haute mer mais une intervention sur un
voilier qui peut se passer de nuit ou en
mergeté bon tout de suite on commence à
être un petit peu plus méfiant et à ce
moment-là un bateau qui s'en est sur moi
qui me fonce dessus presque donc
j'essaie de me pousser parce que
on peut avoir des collisions
il y a une petite carte où tu peux
vérifier qu'est-ce que c'est le bateau
que c'est le point mais c'est marketing
de pétrole je sais pas il risque
d'arriver rapidement dans ton décor
donc essayer de me pousser mais plus
j'essaie de me pousser puis ça
prochainement
on arrive dans le noir complet
sous les projecteurs
la surprise c'était pas
je reçois un appel qui me dit le Livie
est à portée du de la vedette des
douanes le contrôle va commencer
on voit ça c'est impressionnant d'être
sur une annexe au milieu du nuage t en
fait les vagues sont plus hautes que
vous avez des masses noires qui qui
arrivent vers vous et franchement
quelqu'un de plutôt relax à la base mais
là je me dis effectivement ça me permet
de compliqué
puis là il nous disait bon monter à bord
un peu mon tabac pour vérification
je viens me placer à côté du hauban et
mes deux premiers collègues commencent à
attraper le lit le livre nous on est
très léger et le bateau s'est dérobé
sous ses pieds il y a un écart de 2 m
d'un coup en fait en moins d'une seconde
et en fait il se retrouve pendu au
dessus de la mer dans le noir avec une
mérité
partir d'un zodiaque monter dans un
bateau c'est pas toujours évident
c'est pas évident parce qu'en fait il
est sur une filière c'est des câbles en
acier quoi en fait ce qui doivent lui
blesser les mains non non franchement il
était en situation critique
[Musique]
du coup je
sers les dents je visais je tape juste à
côté de lui mon chef mécano va
l'attraper et le remettre à l'intérieur
de notre zodiaque
c'est un moment les plus intenses de ma
carrière effectivement
donc il a pas réussi à monter à bord ça
fait mal aux mains un peu donc ils nous
ont
ordonné de faire Saint-Martin
donc
on obtient pas on me rappelle pour me
dire finalement les conditions de merde
ne sont pas favorables le contrôle et
n'est plus envisager ce soir et a priori
on déroute le bateau vers un port
français pour faire un contrôle à l'abri
et donc je vais me coucher je vais
dormir en me disant bon ben il fera jour
demain
[Musique]
sur à ce moment-là on trouve un peu un
peu bizarre qui insiste qui nous laisse
pas partir il y en a pas l'impression
d'être d'ailleurs la loi donc on
continue à se poser des questions
demandez pourquoi qu'on peut pas aller
plus loin moi je suis fatigué je suis
brûlé je me suis dit bon j'ai dit allô
de ce que tu veux prendre la barre du
bateau je lui dis moi je vais aller
dormir un peu
je suis allé me coucher
[Musique]
le jour arrive à 6h et 7h du matin
je sors sur le la passerelle supérieure
et là on regarde le TV on aperçoit
nos deux infracteurs potentiels en train
de descendre dans leur annexe et ils
sont en train de d'abandonner leur
navire
[Musique]
pourquoi ils font ça c'est complètement
improbable on est à 150 km déco 200 km
des côtes et là il rentre dans une
petite annexe avec un radeau de survie
enfin on comprend pas trop pourquoi ils
font ça quoi un moment donné
on s'est aperçu que ça sentait le boulot
et que ça chauffait on a pris l'annexe
et les bateaux sauvetage et on est sur
le terrain
on commence à avoir une petite fumée qui
sort du navire puis une petite flamme et
d'un seul coup pour mon a une flamme qui
monte qui monte au moins au moins à la
hauteur du Mario
[Musique]
le bateau on appelle pour me dire que le
bateau est en flamme
et donc
je suis un petit peu un petit peu
chagrin voir un petit peu énervé parce
qu'il se passe
mais bien sûr mon premier réflexe de me
dire que les
potentiels preuves je sais pas encore si
comme ici d'une infraction mais ça
commence à faire beaucoup je me dis que
les preuves sont en train de partir en
fumée
là c'est vraiment une surprise
c'est jamais arrivé
l'histoire de la toile je pense on se
dit on est face à de loulous vraiment
intéressant
tout d'abord
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé quand moi
je dors tu comprends
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé il y a
peut-être un petit bout de choses que je
me souviens pas puis j'ai pas entendu
mais
c'est pas possible
tout de suite le chef mécano part avec
une lance sur l'avant du bateau le
capitaine se met juste à côté du bateau
mais avec le vent dans le dos pour pas
avoir des retours de flamme ni de la
fumée qui va qui va venir vers nous et
qui pourra endommager notre bateau ou
intoxiquer le personnel
[Musique]
si on était à la dérive on n'est pas
assez comme entre les deux bateaux
de ce que la mère nous fait circuler
fuck you
[Musique]
ils sont du coup à portée de nous mais
par contre la décision sera prise de
Paul et mettre à bord on sait pas s'ils
ont mis le feu volontairement ou pas
je vais rester quelques heures à flotter
à dérive en attendant qu'ils viennent
nous chercher
c'est assez long assez long que je
prenne un coup de soleil en face c'est
dommage il a oublié sa crème solaire
pour faire sa petite navigation sur son
cadeau
[Musique]
après on le garde quand même à vue ils
étaient vraiment juste à côté donc
j'aurais pu les récupérer en 30 secondes
si c'était pas possible
donc
fin de matinée on m'a confirme que on a
pu monter à bord et que
la coque brûlée quand on arrive à
rentrer dedans c'est pas simple il y a
beaucoup d'eau mais
le bateau est étrangement chargé
et là il tombe sur des ballots de
marchandises en grand nombre à
l'intérieur ils sont estampillés Plata
sur scotch noir assez compressé et tout
et on a une étiquette Plata
tout le monde connaît la phrase de Pablo
Escobar plateau
on suppose directement qu'on a une face
à une très grosse affaire de cocaïne
notre test réagit positivement la
cocaïne du coup l'affaire est faite
c'est de la merde
on est pas au courant c'était là à notre
insu mais
c'était peut-être difficile à croire
pour eux mais ils nous disait qu'il nous
croyait pas de toute façon
les deux naufragés abandonnés lors de
mes données de d'aller les chercher et
ensuite de les mettre sur le pont
arrière
ils étaient pas spécialement nerveux ils
étaient pas agressif du tout donc on a
Martin Lepage qui est plutôt habillé en
skipper il rentre pas trop dans le
profil du trafiquant en voilier habituel
et son collègue Langis Bélanger lui se
présente comme un ancien militaire du
Canada et du coup là pareil on n'est pas
tout à fait dans les profils habituels
et à ce moment là et bien se pose
plusieurs questions la toute première
pour moi c'est où est-ce qu'on les
ramène et je décide que ce sera à la
Martinique
[Musique]
je me déplace port de Fort-de-France
pour assister au débarquement des
personnes interceptées et de la drogue
[Musique]
le quai est sous les projecteurs voilà
il fait nuit il pleut un petit peu
mais bon l'ambiance est plutôt
sympathique
[Musique]
moi j'étais menotté devant tout chez moi
c'est comme lorsque tu bosses sur le
chapeau j'imagine ça fait un peu
de foire
la bête de foire
[Musique]
on était deux c'est seulement moi qui
était là parce que j'étais le capitaine
du bateau pour eux c'était moi
l'important
[Musique]
immédiatement on va projeter à une pesée
contradictoire les marins se mettent en
font une chaîne et se passe les ballots
de drogue de l'un à l'autre c'est une
espèce de petite chaîne comme ça avec
tous ces ballots
qui sont posés sur une balance et puis
un officier de police judiciaire qui
note scrupuleusement les quantités
[Musique]
comme ça même dans les Caraïbes c'est
dans les plus belles affaires de la zone
française on a mis un coup sérieux à une
organisation criminelle c'est c'est un
courrudge qui vient d'être porté
donc oui c'était une belle prise
d'ailleurs la présence du préfet et de
l'amiral sont aussi le signe de la
satisfaction de tous les services de
l'État tout le monde est assez heureux
sauf de Québécois
c'était pas vraiment agréable c'est des
moments qui sont assez longs
jusqu'au moment où on m'amène pour la
nuit
la prison de Fort-de-France ou
[Musique]
je m'appelle Clément Godard j'ai 20 ans
de police à mon actif
[Musique]
mon métier c'est de lutter contre la
criminalité organisée et plus
précisément la lutte contre les
stupéfiants
j'ai travaillé personnellement sur
l'affaire de Martin Lepage ça a été
l'affaire qui m'a marqué parce que c'est
une affaire assez particulière de par sa
quantité de cocaïne c'est pas non plus
courant là on est sur des quantités qui
touchent forcément la criminalité
organisée de haut vol
donc nous on les récupère donc le 21
juillet 2018
pour nous c'est à ce moment-là que
l'affaire des morts
[Musique]
Martin Lepage et l'angistre mélangés
sont placés en garde à vue pour trafic
de stupéfiants sous une qualification
criminale c'est-à-dire association
malfaiteurs plus l'importation le
transport de produits stupéfiants
[Musique]
on commence les premières éditions du
savoir un peu c'est quoi cette histoire
pourquoi ils se retrouvent ici nous
l'intérêt c'est de se rapprocher au plus
proche de la vérité pour pouvoir les
présenter à la justice et moi c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est savoir ce que ils
vont pouvoir nous dire ce qu'on va
pouvoir
démontrer
d'où est-ce que ça venait ou est-ce que
ça allait
[Musique]
il explique assez bien Martin quand il
voit qu'ils vont se faire contrôler par
la douane ils prennent un peu peur quand
même et ils se mettent à chercher dans
le bateau voir s'il y a pas quelque
chose de bizarre
j'aurais pu se produire et en fait si
vous cherchent pourquoi ils se font
contrôler on a trouvé ça un peu un peu
louche on est allé faire des petites
vérifications dans le bateau
[Musique]
j'ai rendu compte qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui nous appartenait pas
qui semblait être plutôt des gros sacs
qu'on a conclu qui pouvait être à côté
ils ont l'air assez sur deux et Martin
Lepage nous explique qu'il vienne d'être
chargés à leur insu de la cocaïne dans
son bateau
on l'a pas fait un public traditionnel
qui sont assez posés dans la vie
qui ont une bonne homie un peu propice
aussi au Canada et à la gentillesse
canadienne qu'on connaît et de la
réputation donc voilà nous on n'est pas
du tout
en confrontation avec eux
le reste c'est toute la vérité qu'on a
dit
qu'elle avait mis ça là
on est le bateau avait été
à l'encre pendant extinction à bord on
savait pas ce qu'il y avait ça bon on
avait on va pas dans les dans les
ballasts pour voir qu'est-ce qu'il y en
a les ballasts à tous les jours quand tu
pars en navigation
[Musique]
le gars qui était avec moi puis j'ai dit
bon mon frère a déjà été dans des
expériences comme ça et il s'est fait
prendre il est allé en prison moi je
veux pas aller en prison on va mettre le
feu bateau ça va couler
[Musique]
et moi je prends pas les décisions
fais-le puis arrivé à ce qui vous donne
un ami l'annexe
il y a détruit le rêve
[Musique]
en premier audition et pas très
satisfaisante puisque
[Musique]
sans bien que là-dessus on va pas aller
très très loin on veut bien essayer de
les croire mais un moment il faut que ce
soit crédible
[Musique]
je m'appelle Rodolphe je suis
journaliste en presse écrite donc à
France antique et le quotidien local de
Martinique
on a une info qui a une saisie de une
tonne 5 en mer on s'est conséquent on
sait où on sait que ça aborde un voilier
qui a été récupéré on s'est de
trafiquants
Gérald Darmanin c'était fendu d'un
communiqué pour se féliciter et
féliciter les services de cette saisie
quand même exceptionnelle de
l'équivalent en tout cas de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros
[Musique]
on a les images on a la vidéo on a les
photos effectivement c'est
impressionnant tout était réuni pour que
cette affaire devienne un peu
emblématique
[Musique]
mais c'est au fil des heures et puis de
qu'on déroule un petit peu et qu'on en
apprend un petit peu plus quoi
c'est là où j'apprends que ce bateau
était à bateau très connu qui s'appelle
le Livy qui a fait trois fois le Vendée
Globe
tiens comment ce bateau là qui était un
bateau emblématique on se retrouve dans
la Caraïbe comment il peut se retrouver
entre les mains de de Québécois
j'avais c'était une messagerie comme ça
là et puis d'un seul coup je vais devoir
150p ou la messagerie bloquée il y a eu
[Musique]
la surprise totale quoi tu vois
tu reçois un coup de téléphone oui
bonjour je suis le lieutenant machin on
va avoir tout le monde et vous serez
témoin sous
témoin enfin dans une procédure on a
encore d'assise
bon début de soirée à tous on commence
le buter avec une exclusivité il y a
deux hommes deux rivières du loup qui se
sont fait pincer en Martinique au cours
d'une très impressionnante 16 hydrogue
écoutez bien des ballots et des ballots
de cocaïne une tonne et demie en tout
saisi en pleine mer 5 millions de
dollars
[Musique]
de cocaïne c'est énorme cette historique
et ses deux Québécois ont été pris la
mélancolie
ils ont été remis à l'office central
pour la répression du trafic illicite
des stupéfiants chargés de l'enquête
judiciaire
l'affaire a été reprise dans toutes les
rédactions deux gars du bas du fleuve
qui se font arrêter à des centaines de
mille nautiques d'ici avec une telle
quantité c'était spectaculaire
lorsque l'affaire a éclaté il y a
certains médias qui ont cherché en
savoir plus sur Martin Lepage on parlait
d'un homme sans histoire d'un homme sans
antécédent criminel d'un homme comme on
dit en anglais très loprofile
[Musique]
photos dans le journal
Gaspésie
la photo
[Musique]
pas du tout
une autre quand on a lu les quantités
qu'on a vu ça dans les médias là ça
sentait nulle part aussi ça
que tu veux que il y a rien à dire tu
tombes ça se peut pas c'est la première
fois que tu dis au moins qu'il est
souvent
et là tout à coup j'en suis un courriel
de ma patronne la rédactrice enchère du
soleil qui me tient entendu parler de
cette affaire là
et Martin Lepage je me suis dit écoute
je le connais j'ai une Satan démon puis
lui aussi de s'entendre des mots alors
l'homme dis écoute petite saisir de
cette affaire là et là je me suis mis en
mode Recherche
et je m'aperçois que Martin je ne l'ai
plus comme facebook je me dis soit que
le supprimer soit qui m'a bloqué le seul
réseau social où je le retrouve c'est
sur linken et là il définit comme ce qui
part
pour moi il commence à avoir des petites
additions qui se font sur le plan
logique
[Musique]
mais les un projet tout le temps
il y a des projets qui ont vu le jour il
y en a qui n'ont jamais vu le jour mais
l'unité jamais
là j'ai dit il me reste à aller chercher
le pouls des gens et certains étaient
même assez proches là j'en dirai pas
plus mais tu es assez proche de Martin
Lepage
j'apprends que il était séparé de la
mère de ses deux fils et il était
nouvellement aussi grand-père
et refaisait sa vie avec une nouvelle
femme bon c'était marié trois ans dans
son arrestation 2015
qui était comme ça
que justement il trouvait ça étrange qui
prennent sa retraite comme technicien
bulancier alors j'ai 52 53 ans puis tout
à coup il y a un rythme de vie beaucoup
plus élevé qui semble avoir encore plus
d'argent
est-ce qu'il y a gagné le loto on le
posit est-ce que bon alors ça
questionnait beaucoup les gens
[Musique]
sa femme se vantait de se promener avec
des bagues avec un diamants d'avoir payé
ça Volvo cash
[Musique]
donc pour les gens ça sonnait des
cloches quand tu payes tout content
c'est il y a quelque chose là et ces
gens-là m'ont demandé de protéger leur
identité il y en a qui ont carrément
refusé il y avait trop la trouille
[Musique]
il a tenté le couple ça a pas marché
plus notre côté gaspelier je pense qu'il
va faire ça on stresse pas avec ça
au Québec depuis 38 ans
parce que ça sa conjoint de sa femme me
demande d'intervenir c'est ce que je
fais donc je rencontre madame
j'ai senti très affecté dès le départ
avec beaucoup d'empathie pour Martin
avec
une énergie là
sincère évidente de l'aider bon
elles aussi elle était impactée par
l'événement dans chaque
j'ai représenté plusieurs personnes
associées au crime organisé les
principalement les moteurs criminels et
d'autres organisations aussi alors je
suis familier avec cet environnement là
on voit bien la pression qui qui surdit
à ce moment là il est loin de chez lui
il contrôle rien il fait face à de gros
sentences quand même
c'est spectaculaire
qui n'est pas criminalisé en fait c'est
tout un choc pour lui
je vais leur expliquer à quel point ce
qu'il me disent ne me convainc pas et
surtout je leur dis et c'est sincère et
je pense que c'est sincère et il
ressentent ils le comprennent que
l'affaire extrêmement mal engagée pour
eux et
on n'est pas des criminels on n'a jamais
fait ça on va pas se faire claquer 30
ans
[Musique]
de là on leur explique en fait ce qui va
se passer c'est qu'on demande déjà un
Martin de
qui nous raconte un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui possède
[Musique]
il a une maison d'une valeur de 250
mille dollars il a une Harley Davidson
la loi pénale française permet des
saisies patrimoniales qui sont en
rapport avec la valeur de la marchandise
illégale illicite transporté et que
grosso modo
peuvent craindre pour pour leur
patrimoine je pense qu'on va procéder à
la saisie complète je sais bien donc on
le laisse un peu comme ça le premier
soir
[Musique]
on les ramène au commissariat de France
voilà bon le commissaire de France est
compliqué faut voir que les conditions
de garde à vue sont difficiles il fait
très chaud les lieux sont vétustes
on sait que Martin va passer 24 heures
un peu difficile fin du mois la nuit
le lendemain matin quand on les récupère
là ils ont les gueules un peu cassées la
nuit a été un peu difficile
la garde de vue c'est vraiment un chien
il y a rien de sympa là-dedans c'est de
la grosse merde
je dors dans des cellules ou ça sert
l'urine et tu manges un bout de pain
avec du fromage une journée puis
peut-être une journée d'après si tu es
chanceux il va avoir un peu de jambon
j'ai perdu 4 kilos dans les 4 jours
c'est pas fait pour
agrémenter ton séjour
bien sûr que il croyait pas l'histoire
du début où on disait que on savait pas
qu'il y avait la drague à mort c'est
[Musique]
bien que
c'était loin de la réalité et quoi il y
a pas que c'était
lors de votre deuxième édition soit vous
continuerez à déclarer ce que vous
déclarez et c'est indiqué que moi je
dirais les conséquences et que je crois
que je ne serai pas le seul soit vous
avez une approche un peu plus
intelligente un peu plus constructive un
peu plus responsable et ça ne peut pas
vous nuire ce serait dans votre intérêt
donc finalement on a décidé de changer
notre version puis d'expliquer vraiment
ce qui s'était passé
[Musique]